[Music]
in other news this morning florida's
legislature is one step closer to
passing a controversial bill that would
restrict any talk of sexual orientation
and gender identity in classrooms
critics call it the don't say gay bill
they say it would hurt lgbtq students
and families manuel bajorquez spoke with
the bill's author manny good morning
good morning that republican state
representative told us this is about a
parent's right to know what their
children are being taught and said the
subject matter is not appropriate for
the earliest grade levels but critics of
the bill call it the latest salvo in a
conservative culture war that is putting
politics ahead of vulnerable children
todd and jeff delmay say their
12-year-old son blake's public school in
hollywood florida has been a welcoming
place from preschool till
fifth grade it's been a great experience
we felt very accepted they feared the
bill that passed the florida house and a
similar one expected to pass in the
state senate could change that if
children are not feeling that they are
accepted or who they are and the family
they come from isn't accepted it will
have an impact on them the parental
rights and education bill says classroom
instruction by school personnel or third
parties on sexual orientation or gender
identity may not occur in kindergarten
through grade three parents could sue
school districts for violations
republican state representative joe
harding sponsored the house bill we want
focus to be on those basic fundamental
things the reading the writing the math
and when discussions come up as a data
for kids children ask questions
discussions are going to come up we
can't ban a conversation we can't ban a
discussion that's not what we're doing
but critics say just the threat of
lawsuits could have a chilling effect on
those discussions and language in the
bill banning those lessons when not age
appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students in accordance
with state standards could arguably
apply to any grade joe saunders is with
equality florida so
it applies to k-12 classrooms and it
grants the right for any parent who
believes that a conversation is
happening about our families to sue a
school district it's an aggressive
attack nationwide there are 18 similar
bills moving through nine state
legislatures the advocacy group the
traver project has denounced them it
says its research shows lgbtq students
who learned about lgbtq issues or people
at school had 23 percent lower odds of
reporting a suicide attempt in the past
year you may have lgbtq youth who do not
have a supportive home environment
so
wouldn't the school be a safe place
and isn't that necessary i think the
schools are a safe place and they need
to continue to be a safe place this
wouldn't change that this doesn't change
a school being a safe place
seventeen-year-old andrew triolo says
even without the bill not all schools
are safe for people like him he is
transgender and has been bullied or
harassed he says out of every public
school he's attended i think that if i
would have had the language to express
how i felt about my gender at a younger
age it would have saved me a lot of
internal struggle and depression he
recently spoke out against the bill at
the state capitol i should get to go to
school clubs and
pick my
activities in school but i'll never get
to experience that like you did i feel
like people tend to boil down sexuality
to just sex
and that's
not what it is in the slightest i mean
there's romantic attraction there it's
culture it's it's identity it's
self-expression and that is i think very
important not to silence that
florida governor ron desantis has
signaled his support for those bills
making their way to his desk but
certainly florida is not the only
battleground the governor of texas this
week told health agencies in that state
that they should investigate gender
affirming treatments for trans
adolescents as child abuse nate
inclusivity should be something every
student has manuel thank you